there's this thing that exists this this
multi headed snake and it's got this
infinity problem it's everywhere that's
that little circle down there and the
problem is well what do you do with that
you cut off one head seven more growth
that's the eternal problem of life and
the problem is there there there is the
category of problems in life and it
ain't going anywhere and so the question
is can you deal with the whole category
at the same time that's the thing that's
how to be in the world is to deal with
that category all at the same time and
so how did you how did you Minh beans
what did they come up with as a solution
and that's so cool too because the
solution they come up with not only was
the heroism that allows you to approach
what you're terrified by and what you
find offensive and to learn from it but
also the idea of sacrifice and and I was
played out by cultures everywhere
including human sacrifice
and you think what the hell was up with
those crazy bastards so long ago they
were sacrificing two gods all the time
what kind of clueless behavior was that
burned something and please God burn
something valuable and please God it's
like what was with that what were they
thinking well they weren't stupid those
people if they were stupid we wouldn't
be here they were not stupid and believe
me they lived under a lot harsher
conditions than we do so those were some
tough people man you know back then
you'd last about 15 minutes and so you
don't want to be thinking of your
ancestors as stupid like there's no real
evidence that we're much different
cognitively than we were a hundred and
fifty thousand years ago so anyways
sacrifice what does that mean sacrifice
well it's a discovery man it's the
discovery of the future it's like the
future is actually the place where there
is threat and it's always going to be
there so what do you do you make
sacrifices in the present so that the
future is better right everyone does
that that's what you're doing right now
that's what you're doing here that's
what your parents are doing when they
pay money to send you to university they
think that you can bargain with reality
it's amazing you can bargain with
reality you can forestall gratification
now and it will pay off it at a place in
time the does
even exist yet it's like who wouldn't
believe that it's like that's a miracle
that that occurs and it's not like
people just figured that overnight you
know we were chimps for Christ's sake
like how are we going to come up with an
idea like that
well it's like well we thought about it
for seven million years and you know we
got to the point where we could kind of
act it out but we didn't know what we
were doing but it was a merge it's like
a dream so the terror of the future is a
dream and the solution to the terror the
dream of the terror of the future is
another dream and and it comes out in
mythology and in fantasy and in drama
where you act out the sacrifice and then
it's a step on the way to full
understanding so we can say sacrifice
now instead of doing it you know
although we still do it it's just not
concretize like it used to be we do it
abstractly and we all have faith that it
will work you know and we also set up
our society so that it'll work and one
thing about you know I'm not a fan of
moral relativism for a variety of
reasons partly because I think it's an
it's an extreme form of cowardice but
anyways apart from that no no no no
there's minimal ways that you can set up
a society that will work and so one of
them is is that the society has to be
set up so that your sacrifices will pay
off or you won't work and then the
society will die and so it has to make
promises people have to make promises to
one another that's what money is money
is a promise that your sacrifice will
pay off in the future
that's what money is and so if the
society is stable you can store up your
work right now you can sacrifice your
impulses and you can work and you can
store up credit for the future and then
you can make the future a better place
but society has to be stable enough to
allow for that hyperinflation will do
you in so the promise that's implicit in
the currency is the promise that what
you're doing now will pay off in the
future and if people don't have that
promise then well we know what they do
because in in gangs for example and say
gangs in North America the time horizon
of the gang members shrinks rapidly
because they don't really
expect to be alive that much past 21 and
so they get really impulsive and violent
and like why the hell not
that's that's what you do when when the
future doesn't matter when it's not real
you you default back to living in the
moment and you take what you can get
right now and no wonder because you
don't know if you're going to be around
in a year and you get whatever you can
well you can bloody well get it and
that's like anarchy that state and so
you don't want to live and some people
like to live in that state because
they're really wired for that you know
and so they're they're much more
comfortable in those conditions they're
they're kind of like warrior types I
would say in some sense but you know for
most people that's just where that
stress will just do you in you know the
stress of a life like that so